so we've already talked about the
general idea the thesis that if the
return on capital is greater than the
growth of an economy that that could
lead to inequality although we showed a
case where depending on the
circumstances with the right numbers
that's not necessarily going to happen
but what i want to do in this video is
to think critically a little bit about
some of the other data from the book and
once again my point right over here is
not to support or go against the ideas
in the book but really just give you
tools for thinking a little bit more
critically about all of these ideas and
what's really neat as i mentioned in
previous videos is piketty makes all of
his data available all of his charts
available at this website right over
there now this is neat because this
shows us the after tax rate of return
versus growth rate at the world level
and you don't see many charts that start
at the year 0 and go over the course of
2000 years and so you can imagine that
the numbers back here are are estimates
but let's just go with them for the for
the sake of argument so what it shows
here is that the annual the annual
return or rate of growth so this is the
pure return of capital after tax and
capital losses so after whatever taxes
and any losses in the value of the
capital or whatever else
that's that here and then this is the
growth rate of world output and you see
for most of at least the last few
thousand years of human history and this
the horizontal axis here isn't
completely at scale from here to here is
that's from here to here gets us almost
well almost 1500 years while from here
to here is
gets us about 50 gets us about 50 years
so it's not completely at scale but you
see that for most of human history the
annual rate the the growth of the
economy was much smaller than the return
on capital and once again these are
especially back here these are just
you know estimates especially based on
feudal times and whatever else but on
some level they could be believable
because in fueled feudal times and when
you had kings and all of that you had a
lot of coercive power by the the feudal
lords or the kings and whoever else they
could by force force people to to kind
of work uh on on their on their fields
or or whatever else but if we if we take
these numbers we then see something
interesting happens as we go into the
early 20th century the return the after
tax rate the after tax return on capital
drops below
drops below the rate of economic growth
of the economy so we see that right over
here and this is over huge swaths of
time even this data point this is this
is one data point that represents this
represents 37 years right over here
and then we have another data point that
represents the next the next what is
this the next 62 years right over that
and this is kind of the world that most
of us kind of know this is modern times
right over here where the rate of
economic growth the rate of world output
has been larger than the rate of
the rate of return on capital after
taxes now when you first just look at
this chart you say oh my god look
they're going to cross again maybe that
means we're going back to the gilded age
or feudal times or whatever else but you
have to be very very very careful here
everything after this point is
conjecture this is a this is a model it
might happen or it might not we could
see something very different so let me
let me make it very
let me let me make it very clear all of
let me just in another color
one that's
so all of this that i'm high oops that's
not another color
all of this
that i'm highlighting in yellow
this over here is all is all conduct
conjecture you could go the other way it
is possible it's completely possible
that
you have a reality let me get my
where
this
continues the trend that it's going on
where this
where world growth kind of does this
actually
and then it goes so it goes from here
and maybe it does something like this so
it's very important to realize that this
this kind of intersection right over
here this is a projection and you should
look at his assumptions you should
decide for yourself on whether you think
that this projection makes sense because
this is what is saying that hey this
this this delta between r and g
that r that that g is greater than r
this makes it look like hey it's it's
over but maybe it's not over maybe when
we average over the next
if we average over the next what is this
going to be over if if we average over
the next 38 years and maybe we get
something like this and obviously we're
just the very beginning of this interval
so there's not a lot to go on and that
is also assuming even if this does
happen that is still
assuming this
this relationship that r
greater than g
leads to inequality
which in extreme forms could eventually
lead to some form of a gilded age or or
kind of dynastic wealth which could hurt
innovation or which could even hurt hurt
let me write that down dynastic
dynastic wealth
gilded age which maybe hurts
hurts
hurts meritocracy
meritocracy
or or even potentially innovation
innovation
or the economy as a whole if you have
less of a middle class and people with
purchasing powers but there's a lot of
arrows here and you need to decide for
yourself which parts of these which
parts of this connection you agree with
or disagree with or depending on the
circumstances or the evidence you are
more inclined to believe or not